Thanks everyone for joining us for this talks at Google event.
We have two fantastic authors here for you today,
Cory Doctorow and John Scalzi.
So we're a great school.
They're [inaudible]
author of walkaway.
So Cory is a science fiction author,
activist,
journalist,
and blogger.
He's the Co editor of boing boing boing boing.net and the author of the
bestselling little brother,
which is actually just recently optioned by paramount.
So it's going to be a movie with Don Murphy producing pretty cool stuff.
So he's also the former European director of the Electronic Frontier Foundation
and he cofounded the UK Open Right's group.
He was born in Toronto,
Canada and now lives in Burbank.
That's the best for Toronto or for Bro.
That's retarded.
No,
no Burbank glove.
Okay.
And then we have John Scalzi,
author of the collapsing empire.
He's one of the most popular and a claimed SF authors to emerge in the last
decade.
His massively successful debut old man's war SF has in science now that,
not saying that not San Francisco is massively successful.
Debut old man's war won him the science fictions.
John W.
Campbell Award for best new writer is New York Times bestsellers include the
last colony,
fuzzy nation and red shirts,
which one 2013 Hugo award for best novel and Lockin material from is widely read
blog,
whatever has also earned him two other Hugo awards.
He lives in Ohio with his wife and daughter.
And let's put our hands together for them.
The welcome [inaudible].
Hello.
Hello
Cory.
Hello John.
It's nice to see you again now.
It's been so long since it has.
So John is at the very end of his tour and I'm at the very start of mine.
John has come from my future to warn me about the terrible catastrophes and the
coming weeks,
right?
It's hydrate and hand sanitizer.
These are the two things that will get you through,
uh,
most of these particular events,
right?
Well,
hydration hydrational gets you through times of no hand sanitizer better than
hand San Antonio and the handset.
And how did we get you through challenges or no hydration?
There's so much truth in that statement.
I don't even know where to start anywhere.
Realize it's all US halfway through it.
That it's actually true is actually true.
You are trying to be,
you're generally trying to be arching yet you're actually spoken a home truths
that is truly useful to people who are on the electric hand sanitizer.
Don't drink hand sanitizer.
I mean,
no matter,
no matter how fruity it smells,
it's just,
it's going to end in pain.
Yeah,
that's right.
But you do,
I mean,
you do see a lot of people and you shake a lot of hands in the very first time
that I ever went on tour,
I shook somebody's hand in San Diego and the next thing I knew I was in
Minneapolis and Phoenix was somewhere in between that and it's just like,
can't,
can't do that again.
I don't know what I did in Phoenix,
but I can't ever back to that city now.
So,
so,
uh,
so John,
you wrote this book,
the collapsing empire,
a kind of eco catastrophe that you didn't realize it was an equal catastrophe
until the review started coming in.
Well,
yeah.
What happened was this is the,
this is the classic idea of the author,
so fixated on their own specific idea that they don't really think about,
uh,
necessarily about the obvious wider implications that are clear to everyone
else.
In my specific case,
when I was writing the club scene empire,
um,
I was thinking about,
uh,
the age of sail and the age of empires.
I,
you know,
basically between,
uh,
the 15th through the 18th centuries,
in Europe.
And,
uh,
and what I was thinking about,
what would happen to all those empires in Europe,
you know,
Portugal,
the UK,
Spain,
um,
if all of a sudden the jet stream and the ocean currents of just suddenly went
away or shifted so significantly that all the things that they took for granted
about how they were going to get around the world to get to the new,
uh,
you know,
the new world order to get to Japan just suddenly disappeared.
Um,
and this is relevant to me because I created,
because I,
because I strongly believe that the speed of light is not only a good idea but
actually the law and that you wouldn't want to go close to the speed of light
anyway cause anytime you hit something spaces only mostly empty.
Right?
Um,
so that when you hit something of course,
boom,
that to all turns into energy and your doom.
Um,
so I created this,
uh,
this thing called the flow,
which is a sort of a extra dimensional conduit that gets you from one place to
another because it doesn't have to obey the rules of this particular university
because it sort of sits on top of it.
It's basically a cheat but a very interesting cheat.
But it works like ocean currents or it works like a,
the jet stream.
Um,
and uh,
it's a feature of the universe that we have no control over.
And so they built this entire empire using the flow.
Just assuming that the flow is always going to be there because as far as they
know,
it always has been,
but the universe doesn't care what you think about permanence or what you need.
It's basically just going to do what it's going to do and eventually the flow
goes away.
So I'm busy thinking about these parallels too,
you know,
ocean currents and the flow and people coming up to me,
uh,
at a,
at these events and then go on.
It's about oil,
isn't it?
And I'm like,
I guess it is,
you know,
because it's the thing that happens where you have a,
you,
you write something and you put it out in the world and it's no longer a just
exclusive to your brain.
It is now in dialogue with what's,
and the brain of somebody else.
Uh,
so the person who is looking at it going,
this is obviously about oil or this is obviously about climate change or this is
obviously about such and such.
Sometimes they,
you know,
they can get really wacky about it,
but other times it's like,
Yup,
cause I also live in,
I live in the now.
Right?
And I do actually think about oil and climate change and even if I'm not
thinking about them directly,
obviously they're going,
that sort of stuff is going to seep into what I do.
I also wonder if there isn't a parallel to be drawn though with a sort of theory
free knowledge,
right?
So one of the thing that brings all these people into catastrophe is that they
don't really know how the flow works,
right?
But it's worked so well for so long that they assume it will be stable.
And we have a lot of things that we do that are kind of folk ways rather than
reality.
You know,
we'll ab split our way into some optimal pattern that we don't really know why
it works.
And so we used to bet it's stable for a long time and so we build up big
edifices on it and then all of a sudden it,
it changes or it turns out that it's fragile.
What happens is like,
uh,
an example,
science fiction fandom.
There's this saying that Jay,
if you do something once,
it's a tradition.
If you do it twice,
it's a hollow tradition.
And what that means is that people get so used to doing things heuristically
they don't even question whether that process makes sense outside of that
specific thing.
Um,
and we do as humans we do things.
So heuristically it's like,
why do you do this?
Because it's always worked.
Why do you do it this way?
Well,
because then when I did it the other way,
it didn't work the way I wanted to.
So I'm always going to do this.
Can you explain why this works the way it does?
It just works the way it does.
Stop asking me these questions.
I have things to do.
Um,
we do things.
So heuristically,
um,
that what we ended up doing is we,
we become trapped to a process without understanding how the process works.
And that's of course how we fold down,
you know.
Now let's segue a little bit into walkaway.
Sure.
And we were talking about,
uh,
one of the things that you do in,
um,
in walk away is that you actually pause it,
that a lot of people are actually going to cooperate in trying times,
uh,
rather than go,
oh no,
it's every person for themselves and low and let's,
you know,
get at it.
Now,
there were some people who had say heuristically that when you go and,
uh,
have a crisis,
the thing that you should do is just sort of look out for yourself and assume
that everybody else is going to take care of themselves.
Do you,
you don't have,
so I mean,
the theory that a 99.9% of people are total bastards.
It has a,
has a really significant statistical,
a problem with it,
which is that the people who have,
it's this theory almost always also say,
but not you,
me and all the people we know,
right?
So the likelihood in a world where 99.9% of people are total bastards,
that everyone that you know isn't,
is really low.
Right?
It's much more likely that the people that you know,
our,
our representative selection of the people around them and that they have the
dual nature of all fragile and imperfect humans,
which is to say that on a good day they a rise to the occasion and on a bad day
they do things that haunt them forever as their regrets.
And what,
what really matters in terms of a society is not how it works when it's working
well.
But what lessons it teaches us that come to mind easily when things go wrong.
You know,
the
liquidation preference for a civilization that's based on a every person for
themselves.
My gain is your loss.
Uh,
let's all be rational self interested actors and through that will emerge some,
some kind of competitive but optimized world is that when things go wrong,
you see your neighbors as your competitors and not as your potential saviors are
people with whom you have some kind of mutual destiny or a mutual responsibility
to,
and you know,
all of the stories that we have through our history of civilizations falling in
ways large and small,
whether that's just the lights going up because the power plant collapsed her
because we had a horrible quake or,
or whatever or all the way up to the fall of the empire.
Every one of those situations was not resolved by the people who ran to the
hills.
Right.
By definition,
when you run to the hills,
you do not solve those problems.
It's also by the people who run to the middle,
right.
To see how they can help.
And you know,
coordinating that help is hard.
And I always feel like there's,
um,
a lot of drama latent in the story of people who agree with each other on what
should be done,
but disagree about how it should be about how it should be done.
And that it's actually a much more compelling drama in the,
in the end than the easy drama of people who actually disagree about what should
be done.
Right.
The band versus man story is a lot less interesting than we're all on the same
side,
but I hate you and I want to kill you.
A story which is something that,
you know,
as much harder to resolve as anyone who's ever gone to Christmas dinner with
their family can tell you.
Right?
Uh,
and so walk away is a,
a story about people who are consciously trying to,
uh,
form societies that fail gracefully instead of societies that work well and that
they're trying to use the coordinate of latent power of technology to get there.
That rather than thinking about technology as the thing that helps us
manufacturer communicate that they're thinking about it as a thing that lets us
add our labor.
One to the other.
Um,
even if we don't all agree on what's to be done,
and if it turns out that I throw some code or some work into a project that
turns out to be superfluous to it,
that's okay.
We can just,
we can just leave it by the wayside or,
you know,
factor it out in,
in,
in future revisions that,
um,
rather than having someone sit down and tell us all what to do,
we all do what we think needs to be done.
And we have a tool that lets the parts of it that are useful,
glom together so that,
you know,
today we can build an encyclopedia the way that we used to,
apply bureaucracy to the problem of building a bake sale.
Uh,
and tomorrow maybe we could build skyscrapers and space programs that way,
you know,
without the kind of coerce of hierarchical control.
Maybe we can use additive labor to do it.
I see you shaking your head.
Perhaps you should read the book,
but,
uh,
but there are a lot of people who said they didn't want to Wikipedia
encyclopedia for about 10 years.
Right.
And there were a lot of people who said that they didn't want to go new
operating system for about 10 years and they were really right for the first 10
years.
Right.
That's the amazing thing.
Like it's,
you know,
as,
as you mean whale says it is a complete disaster in
theory,
it only works in practice.
Right?
Well here's,
but here's,
here's a question,
um,
that,
and one of the things that you can say is,
uh,
all right,
so the idea that cooperation is kind of a,
one of thing,
not to be disputed,
but how do you keep a wonderful thing,
a wonderful communal thing from basically being swamped by the bastards?
Well,
and that's a problem that the people in this story a really contend with,
you know,
are,
we have,
um,
uh,
a new move in the 21st century for resolving disputes,
which is forking,
uh,
it's,
I mean,
it's not entirely new.
It's just lower costs than it's ever been.
There's this thing in Canada where the further west you go,
the weirder the Mennonites get because,
uh,
men and autism is a schismatic faith because it,
it,
it has this article that you shouldn't be worldly,
but worldly is not a crisply defined a idea.
And so what's one person's worldliness is someone else's nom worldliness.
I have a friend who's grown,
who grew up in a Mennonite community that was founded by people who disagreed
about whether or not vertical blinds were cool,
right?
They,
they thought they were the people who are old order thought they shouldn't be.
And so they moved west,
right?
So you get all the way west to Saskatchewan and there's that wonderful science
fiction writer named Carl Schrader who's uh,
a second multigenerational Mennonite.
His father was a Mennonite TV repairmen.
Right?
And so this was like somehow reconcilable with this,
this,
uh,
this faith,
right?
So that's a very expensive way of,
of,
of skimming.
But we have a much cheaper way of skimming now,
which is that we can,
but we can fork the code,
we can keep the code bases reconciled,
but we can,
we can add stuff on it,
on top of it.
And so,
you know,
the kind of Debbie into a boon to model of,
of,
um,
of skimming is a,
is a much more interesting one because it allows for a lot of experimentation at
the margin,
right?
You can do a lot of like parallel universe stuff where it's like,
well,
what if we rerun Debbie again but we gave up on this principle or we included
some non-free repositories and we did something else that wasn't,
you know,
that was key core to Debbie.
And,
and then you get to find out like,
what's up,
how's it work?
Instead of having a kind of abstract argument,
you can actually try it and see what happens.
So it's like a choose your own adventure.
It's or,
or,
or like parallel multiple parallel universes.
And so the walkaways for better and for worse.
You know the,
the,
the thing about walkway,
it's as this sort of burning man ish co subculture,
but what it is,
is they walk away from the world.
They find Brownfield sites that have been left behind by the collapse of
industrial civilization.
They harvest the waste stream that's exhausted off what's left of postindustrial
industrial civilization and using cool tools.
They build fully automated leisure communism.
And if someone comes along and says,
you know,
that patch of dirt is mine and that garbage that you're using doesn't belong to
you.
Rather than argue about it,
they just go somewhere else because they'd like all garbage and patches of
blighted land are fungible.
And so they just go find somewhere else to,
to,
to try out their experiment.
And they're able to do this for better or for worse.
And the worse is that they,
that there are times when doing that actually does cost them something right and
that they,
that they can't always reconcile it.
And then the people who,
uh,
who have kicked them off plot of land a,
sometimes aren't happy with them walking to plot of land be sometimes there
mortally offended that they've walked off in an in particular when I'm the
walkaways who are walking away or our scientists who've taken the practical cure
for death,
uh,
out of the default world and,
and,
and kind of stolen fire from the gods and brought it to everyone else done.
I'll kind of,
Aaron Swartz,
cy hub,
kind of,
uh,
exfiltration of the,
to have the technology necessary for mortality.
The super rich realize that they're going to have to spend the rest of eternity
with us and become really,
really upset about it.
And walking away ceases to be a viable strategy.
Now they have to start running away.
Yeah.
I love watching you talk
cause he,
the funny thing about Corey is,
is like he like Corey,
here's the thought and he goes so formal and now this comes out like 10,000
ideas in this,
in this,
uh,
stream like a,
you know,
you're,
you're the fire hose of ideas.
Well that's kind of,
it's,
but it's true though.
And it's like,
so when they,
when we were first talking to them,
they were like,
oh,
we want to pair you up with Corey.
I'm like,
yeah,
sign me up.
I am the,
I am the carbon fuel or the carbon rod to his nuclear fuel,
cause he's going to go all over the place and I'm going to be okay.
Here we go.
I love this analogy.
I love that you're the nerd carbon road.
Uh,
but,
uh,
now actually,
here's the thing that,
uh,
we had talked about in previous things and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
uh,
approach it to you a little bit.
Uh,
one of the things that we,
we were talking about is one of the,
uh,
the issues of,
um,
way back when with primogeniture and how that related to colonialism.
Primogeniture means the only one person,
usually it's on inherits.
Um,
and then colonialism to accent solved that problem because,
uh,
you could go from,
you know,
you could take those second and third sons or whatever and have them find their
own fortunes out in the world.
Um,
and eventually it exhausts itself because there's only so much world out there.
and that was,
uh,
leads to a kind of collapse that cost,
for example,
World War One,
and then as a consequence of World War II.
Um,
but let me,
let me apply that to the,
to the world of the walkways.
One of the,
one of the posits here is that when you fork you can just go somewhere else
sooner or later.
Don't you run up,
run out of somewhere else?
Yeah.
So,
so,
uh,
in that regard,
um,
so,
so to,
to kind of reiterate this,
this earlier part Toma Piketty and capital in the 21st century,
he hypothesizes that the age of colonialism created allowed every family to
create as many dynastic fortunes as they had sons.
And that eventually you run out of colonies that you can get dynastic fortunes
out of.
But the fortunes had a,
had a character of rivalries snus right.
The fortune that I have as a fortune.
You can't have what the walkaways get is like a kind of federated universe of
different,
slightly different variations on their ethics and on their,
on their,
uh,
design aesthetics and on their practices,
their engineering practices are there social practices.
And so you're right that there may,
there may be some element that is optimal for you that's not,
that isn't perfectly suited in any of the places,
but they're also not super intensely specified.
So,
you know,
the like the likelihood that there's something that's really important to you
that no one will tolerate and you can't find anywhere to do it,
that's a pretty low likelihood,
right?
It's,
it's,
you know,
and this coordination,
it's a really remarkable thing.
In fact,
one of the impetuses for this book was a thing Google did.
Uh,
they um,
uh,
you guys built a data center in Belgium in a a valley where a two thirds of the
time you don't need chillers.
It's the ambient temperature is low enough that you don't need chillers.
And the rest of the time they just shut off the servers because the file system
is distributed and the you can coordinate the labor.
And this was a,
a remarkable realization for me that we could,
um,
we could use coordination to simply shunt around resources to wherever their let
least environmentally catastrophic,
wherever they are kind of most harmonious with the rest of the world.
And then we could realize these new efficiencies that,
um,
really challenged the notion that you can't have infinite growth in a finite
world.
Uh,
infinite growth implies that you don't have any kind of process automation and
you don't have any changes in what people want.
Right.
Uh,
and that,
that,
you know,
we'll just keep growing well,
like keep making cars that have x tons of steel on them and we can do that
infinitely.
That's obviously not true,
but there doesn't seem to be any bottom insight to how few tons of steel you can
put in a car.
And so in that regard,
we can get some,
some extremely flexible growth out of there.
And then when you add to that using coordination to move cars and people close
to each other when they need them,
and then apart when they don't,
boy,
you can sure get a lot of cars,
people's miles seats without having to necessarily multiply the number of tons
of steel by the number of people,
uh,
to get the number of cars,
the effective use of the car as opposed to the sheer number of cars.
Right,
right.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's better than then the mere despotic dominion over a car that after all,
you then have to take care of and find a place to put and right.
And all the rest of it.
It's like [inaudible] and which is inevitably the third best car,
the fifth best car as opposed to the very best car for your needs because you
can't afford that.
Uh,
the,
the interesting movies,
science fiction,
one of the best moves of science fiction is to take a technological phenomenon
and see if it can be extracted from it social and economic context and whether
it still works.
This is a steam punk,
right?
Like,
what is,
what does it mean if you could like have the machines without the factory,
right?
Mad scientists could do productivity,
uh,
that are characteristic of an assembly line,
but they could do it all alone in their labs,
right?
Um,
to imagine something like fleet vehicles without market capitalism,
right.
Without,
without even communal ownership.
Mark,
uh,
you know,
that we're just a kind of epic phenomenon of cooperative work without any
formalized structures that that's how like,
it's a really provocative thought experiment to imagine what kind of
arrangements we'd get out of that.
I wish I had a car and then then a car drives up and you go and do your car and
then you say goodbye car.
Thank you for driving me.
Right?
And if it turns out there are no cars,
then,
then some other thing that you might want to do is brought to your attention
that doesn't require a car.
You know,
there's a whole a group of people and walk away that are,
um,
uh,
the remnants of,
of,
uh,
investment bubble in Zeppelins.
Uh,
and they,
they,
you know,
just like the,
20 years ago we had this investment bubble that,
um,
use pension funds to teach humanities majors how to write Java script,
uh,
w w this,
this,
and this.
This bubble turns a whole ton of disaffected post-millennials into air ship
builders and pilots but doesn't actually produce so functional airship economy.
And so,
um,
a bunch of them just start building air ships,
but they,
they,
they are non propelled air ships.
They have minimal impellers and so they just go where the winds are blowing.
But because they're,
they were all part of this global phenomenon,
they kind of know somewhere wherever the winds might blow them.
And so it's a kind of movable party,
you sort of check to see who's on the,
the next air ship through town and whether you know them and when you get on the
airship,
you checked to see whether the next town that the wind is blowing you too as a
place where there might be someone you want to hang out with.
Right.
And the,
the,
uh,
automation marries the two.
Right.
Fascinating.
Now,
um,
do you think there are antecedents,
I mean,
not antecedents in,
in your,
uh,
in,
in the human experience,
but antecedents,
uh,
to what you're doing?
Uh,
in science fiction?
I mean,
one of the things that I,
I kind of see walkway being is almost like the seed culture for,
uh,
in banks culture series.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
I think banks is,
banks definitely was,
was writing about what a post scarcity world would look like.
But the,
if there's a difference in our angle,
he's,
he's got this fait accompli.
Sure.
Right.
And I'm,
and I'm thinking about the transitional state,
which is a really interesting moment to think about it.
And his,
his,
uh,
emphasis is really on a manufacturer as opposed to coordination,
right?
So it's his,
you know,
his magical technology is the two dates.
Still rather fanciful idea that,
you know,
matter can be conjured,
organized matter can be conjured up,
out of code,
which,
you know,
not withstanding a few,
three d printers around the margin is not a thing that we do very reliably at
mass scale,
uh,
yet.
Uh,
but for me it doesn't really matter if you've got three d printers and walkway
through it,
walk away,
works pretty good.
Even if all you've got is,
um,
just people who are assembling stuff because they're still able to do process
improvement,
they're still able to feedback to one another.
They're still using software networks to take whatever it is they can make and
make it better on demand continuously all around the world and saw it's it's
hardware that acts like a software object.
Right.
So basically what,
uh,
one of the things that we talked about earlier is like the triangle.
You said of the,
you know,
what you have process.
I tell me,
remind me of the triangle of,
of,
of a post scarcity.
Up here you have what we want.
So Keynes wrote this essay in 1930 about how his grandchildren would struggle to
fill their lives after the 15 hour work week was introduced because there would
be no reason to,
to work beyond that because we could fill all our material wants.
And you know,
the,
the resolution to Keynes is paradox today is that Keynes dramatically
underestimated how much people would want,
but that peoples,
that people's desires where elastic and we're sponsored IV to new material goods
or a cynic might say that people are amenable to marketing messages and one
things that they don't really want.
They can be convinced in the moment that they want something that actually,
and objectively they don't want.
But,
but whatever your explanation is,
right,
that's up in this corner down here you have,
you have the production,
right?
But over here you have what you have the uh,
ability to coordinate what we want with what we can make,
right?
And you know,
the thing that allows,
you know,
the port of Guang Jo to fire a shipping container full of happy meal toys at the
port of Los Angeles,
one a second,
365 days a year.
Like our rail gun firing tchotchke goes,
you know,
is that's coordination right?
At these long supply chains are all built up out of coordination technology.
It's a,
it's a,
a marvel to behold and it's such an everyday marvel that we don't even notice
that when we think about three d printers as being miraculous,
what's really miraculous as that Mcdonald's can sell you a cow with a beef of a
thousand or a burger with a beef,
a thousand cows in it,
right?
That like we can do these incredible complex,
seemingly fragile supply chains that nevertheless are really robust against
even,
you know,
the burgeoning climate problems of,
of long distance shipping and so on.
Sure.
Um,
and the reason I bring that up is because when you were talking about the
triangle you walk away is over here where you're talking about coordination and
someone like,
uh,
banks is over here.
That's right.
Who's up at the top then?
Oh,
well that's the Huxley,
right?
That's,
that's changing what we want.
Or Mary Condo,
right?
That the cottage industry of convincing you that all you really want is a smooth
river rock that reminds you of your mother as quite Ray Sickora said,
uh,
you know,
the,
that,
uh,
you know,
it's the project of Zen Buddhism,
right?
The minimalist project,
it has it.
The biggest enemy of minimalism is procarity.
Right.
One of the major reasons that people hold onto stuff is because they're worried
that their circumstances might change and they might not be able to afford to
get it again.
And if they don't need it now,
you know,
that's why people save their clothes from when they,
before they lost weight or gained weight or whatever.
It's because they know that it would cost them more to replace it in the future
then they might have,
and so it's worth the opportunity cost of leaving it in their closet.
Right.
Well,
no,
it's that whole idea that everybody had a grandmother or great grandmother who
lived through the depression.
Sure.
Had a big ball of string.
Yeah.
Right.
And that big Bob,
what are you going to use the big ball of string for?
You never know what you might be able to use that big ball of string for.
I have a homecoming ritual,
which is throwing it all the nonworking pens in my parents' kitchen.
Right.
Whenever I visit her on,
because they do pilot.
Oh yeah,
they do.
And it's Gresham's law,
right?
The good pens drive out though.
Bad pens drive out the good ones.
Cause the good pens are the ones you take with you and your bag and lose.
And the bad pens of the ones that stay behind.
It's just broken pencils and,
and uh,
you know that in this bag right now I have got like six working pens that I've
stolen from bookstores that have been done.
There we go.
I'm going to rise up the bad,
right because,
and then there'll be like,
oh,
we don't have any good pens.
I was like,
I have one that's so cool.
So John,
you are incredibly generous being at the end of your term,
of your,
of tour,
uh,
with,
with putting the emphasis on my book here,
but I really want to talk more about collapsing empire because it's a
fascinating and cracking read,
right?
And you know,
you say that your,
your um,
I cheerful quippy guy and so people mistake you for an optimist even though
you're right about pastors.
But what I'm interested in is like,
where's the intro?
Why the interest in bastards?
Like what,
what are they just fun to write?
They are fun to write.
I mean,
bastards are bastards are great fun.
You don't want them in your life.
Right.
You know,
and we,
I,
in this particular,
in this particular book,
I have a character who I love,
who's one of my favorite characters that I've ever written and her name is Kiva
Logos.
And she is amazing to read and she's amazing to watch an action.
And you know that if she were your friend and she was calling you,
you know,
it'd be like,
do I want to answer the phone?
Do I want to answer the phone?
Because whatever's going to happen,
it's going to be a thing,
right?
And then I've got to deal with it and I didn't want to deal with it right now I
don't have time for this.
And you put it down and immediately afterwards there's a text that says,
I know you're there.
Pick up the phone,
you bastard.
But with more swearing,
but much more sweet.
She is an epic swear.
And this is you.
Last night we were on tour and he's,
he's like,
you don't swear very much.
How does that,
where does that come from?
And I just stared at him,
right,
because I am,
I,
you don't know,
I ever hear you swear.
I must only catch you in moments of,
uh,
of great,
cheerful,
were very well behaved.
It must be it.
But in fact,
I am,
I am an epic swear and I come from a grand line of epics wares.
And if you get us altogether,
um,
about 60% of our,
of our,
uh,
discourse is swearing in one way or another.
Um,
but she's,
so she's a great character.
Um,
but she's also,
she's also a bit of a bastard.
She's our bastard.
So we like her.
Um,
but,
uh,
you still have to deal with,
you know,
what does that mean in terms of character and story.
And the other thing is,
is as we were talking about the,
how our books,
even though they were completely unrelated to the writing are strangely,
he is looking at,
uh,
the world of a kind of a post collapse.
Um,
and the in the,
uh,
middle class and lower classes dealing with that.
Whereas in the collapsing empire,
it is all focused on the people who are up at the top.
The literal aristocracy,
literal aristocracy and their motivations are,
um,
in some ways very,
very,
very different because they are the main beneficiaries of this entire
interdependent system.
The whole point of this system,
it was built.
Um,
so that,
uh,
the 1% or the actually the one 10th of the one 10th of the 1%,
would benefit basically from every exchange in every transaction that would ever
happen in trade through the space.
Um,
and so when it,
when it,
they have evidence that it's very likely to fail.
Some of it's debatable,
uh,
evidence,
but it is Evan very strong evidence nonetheless.
Um,
they kind of break up into three general areas.
There's going to be the people who say,
um,
get everybody on the boat.
We'll kind of see how many people we can save.
They're going to be other people who are,
there's not enough for him in the boat for everybody.
Kick,
kick,
you know,
they're just make sure my family is on the boat.
And then there are the people who are like,
I don't know whether or not things are coming to an end or not.
All I know is I need to own that boat,
right?
Because they're going to be the person who is,
who is in control.
So their motivations are actually materially different.
Um,
then hoi polloi you know,
trying to get through their day or trying to adjust this world,
their,
uh,
focus is going to be on preservation.
Whether its preservation on a large scale with as many people as possible to
preservation on a small scale with fewer people will,
preservation of wealth and capital or whatever.
Um,
and because of that,
uh,
in many ways,
um,
the impulses that are,
that can be valorized in those particular situations,
uh,
seem to be the ones that also include bastardy.
Right,
right.
I mean it's so I love the cynicism of the,
the political system where it's a,
there's this hub that call,
it's called hub rob that's called hub,
that all the,
all the,
the lay lines converge on and,
um,
the,
the power brokers have granted monopolies on different technologies,
two different spokes,
the Termini of different spokes of the hub such that any no one world is self
sufficient and therefore goods always have to transit hub to get to,
to,
to keep each of the colonies running.
And if the hub ever breaks down,
civilization collapses across,
across space.
Um,
so first of all,
this is a lovely bit of cynicism,
but what I found really great was there,
there's this kind of latent thing,
which I didn't even realize until the book was over.
Cause as they're scrambling to make plans,
even the best of them is not saying,
wait a second,
how do we create resilience independent colonies before the,
the,
uh,
hyperspace loopholes disappear,
because,
um,
they're going to be like literally unreachable for the next million years and
they can't make their own food.
Right?
Right.
And no one's like,
how do we make sure that that distant world has food?
Right.
I love that.
Right?
We're,
we're getting a times signal here at Q and.
A.
So what that means is to very briefly,
there is in fact one character who is leaning in that direction.
Um,
but,
uh,
and the next book I believe is actually going to be about how she tries to sell
back into 100.
Yeah.
I kind of wonder,
it ends on a cliffhanger,
which enraged a lot of people are like,
what?
There's gotta be more.
I'm like,
look,
you know,
there's,
it's a whole universe.
He got you.
He needs a couple of books.
So that book has a surprise ending to the last 40%.
It's just the same word over and over again.
Don't tell anyone it's a spoiler.
But you know,
the punctuation,
the spacing is very different.
It's very,
very different.
It's a,
yeah.
Steganography alright,
so we're going to go into questions now.
Uh,
and we actually have a,
a thing that we like to do where,
uh,
we,
Corey suggested it.
I agree with it.
Uh,
that,
uh,
one question comes from someone who identifies as female or non binary.
The next one comes from someone who identifies as male and nonbinary.
And why do we do that,
Corey?
We do that cause otherwise it's a sausage fest.
Correct.
So we'll start with uh,
or any people identify as female or non binary.
You'd like to ask the first question and there's a mic runner who will come over
for the benefit of the live stream.
Right.
So anyone raise a,
raise your hands,
otherwise we'll move on.
There we go in back the purple.
Okay.
We,
I recognize you from our event last night and Santa Cruz.
Nice to see you again.
Yes.
So is the retention of wealth and moral,
is it retention of wealth?
Immoral?
No,
I don't think the retention of wealth is inherently immoral.
I think there'd be the,
there becomes a point where if your retention of wealth leads to the overall
reduction of wellbeing of other people,
I personally think that's immoral because my moral system says,
uh,
you know,
do as well for everybody.
Uh,
as much as you can in a very,
very general sort of way.
And so when the concentration of wealth,
uh,
means for example,
that we valorize the accumulation of wealth over say the wellbeing of people in,
in realms of health or education or housing or any of those sorts of things.
And it eventually becomes that you really create such a huge disparity between
the top or most one 10th of one 10th of one 10th of 1% and literally everybody
else in the world,
yes,
then it becomes a moral.
But in the sense of a,
in a,
in a very real sense,
wealth is an abstract concept that we all agree to go along.
Um,
and so,
uh,
to some extent we all agreed to that particular delusion.
The problem the fall down is when we,
that all agreed upon delusion means that the majority suffer.
Yeah.
I would take a more like Piketty version of this,
right?
Where Piketty like basically says,
why do we,
why do we tolerate imbalances in wealth?
Right?
Why do we not go and take,
if we want and someone else has,
why do we not go and take and why do we erect systems just to establish stable
property relationships?
And his answer is that,
um,
because when we allocate wealth,
when people can have wealth who are,
uh,
as a result of being good allocators of wealth,
when being a good allocator,
wealth gets you more wealth.
So when you allocate wealth in a way that is beneficial to the world,
you get richer,
then you get more wealth to allocate.
Um,
and the problem is that intergenerational wealth transfer doesn't,
uh,
doesn't create efficient capital allocations.
And his example is to compare Liliane Bettencourt,
who's the eras of the L'Oreal fortune was literally never worked a day of her
life.
And Bill Gates who founded the most successful company in the history of the
world in his lifetime,
and Liliane Bettencourt and Bill Gates starting from the same place at the same
time.
Lillian Betancourt's fortune grew more than Bill Gates did,
even though she didn't even allocate capital,
she just,
she just like gave Capitol to other people to allocate.
And then Bill Gates after he retired may more money still as a in total than he
had while running the largest company in the world.
So Bill Gates doing nothing apart from being a financial plumber as opposed to
doing the like non commodity thing of starting a business that capital can flow
into,
right?
Bill Gates doesn't make as much money and so there's this kind of utilitarian,
uh,
but market oriented reason to do redistribution to,
to,
to care about intergenerational wealth transfer.
But there's a simpler kind of left right version.
So there's a,
a wonderful leftwing fantasy writer named Steven Bruce Hughes.
And I said,
no fooling Trotskyists fantasy writer.
Yes,
he and he,
and,
and uh,
you can tell he's a Marxist fantasy writer because he has the right ratio of
vassals to Lourdes,
a normal,
normal,
normal.
A fantasy writers have way too few vassals but,
uh,
he,
um,
I was having drinks with them once and I said,
I don't even know what left and right mean anymore.
And I said,
he said,
it means exactly the same thing.
It's meant since the French revolution.
You ask what is more important in property,
right or human right.
And if the,
uh,
if the,
person you're asking says property rights are human right there on the political
right,
and that that's the,
that is the question that divides the two philosophies.
And so it,
once you,
once you come to the conclusion that it's not a human right,
that it's merely like a utilitarian thing,
then yes,
of course there's,
there's real problems with intergenerational wealth transfer.
And the other thing about it,
uh,
particularly the United States is,
people have a tendency in the United States to believe that there are two pipe
types of people that are the millionaires and the people who are not the
millionaires yet temporary embarrassed millionaires.
This Steinbeck called them.
Exactly.
And if that is your fundamental view of the world,
then ultimately,
uh,
the,
the question of
wealth accretion does I think 10 towards,
uh,
and morality.
So next question.
So,
uh,
I know,
I hate to say this because I know you met your living doing this,
but,
um,
would you,
uh,
what do you think about the fact that to be successful in a post scarcity world,
you have to completely ignore all intellectual property law?
And I would argue that open source is successful because it found a way to do
just that.
But yeah,
Corey,
I think you've got it wrong about,
about free and opensource software.
I actually think so.
So I think you're right that the free software movement origins are in
opposition to,
um,
to the idea of copyright and patent actually to against intellectual monopoly
more,
more widely.
But it's,
it's a brilliant hack because what Stallman did with the GPL was he created a
regime where the more you strengthen copyright,
the more enforceable his license that that absurd copyright became.
And the weaker you made copyright,
the less his license was needed to accomplish its goals.
And so he,
he,
he created a headache heads.
I win.
Tails you lose situation in the license.
I think that,
um,
the idea of,
uh,
exclusive rights over one's intellectual creations has always been,
um,
a battleground between the utilitarian considerations,
self deception and um,
and emotional feelings,
animal sentiments.
So we have this Lockey and intuition that when we infuse something with our
labor,
it's ours.
And that leads to the self delusion that we,
when we infused it with our labor,
we did not take anything from anyone else that was theirs.
So when Edgar Allen Poe invents the detective story,
he's just making plumbing.
When I write a detective story,
I'm making something special and uh,
and,
and unique to me that no one can take without doing me some irreparable harm.
And then from a utilitarian perspective,
we ask ourselves,
would the world be a better place if you could only write a detective stories of
Edgar Allen Poe's a state said you could.
And it seems pretty clear that they're like detective Po was I named my daughter
after Po.
I'm not,
I,
I will brief for po,
but po had eccentric ideas and if we send to Po,
you are the arbiter of all detective stories because of murders in the room org.
We would be a poor world for it.
And so,
uh,
I am a believer in evidence led a copyright and patent where we can share,
if we can show that at the margin you produce more creativity,
more of whatever the underlying purposes by enacting some temporary monopoly is
specified in the constitution for the promotion of the useful arts and sciences,
then let us do so.
But if we,
um,
but if the only thing we're doing is pandering to the self deception,
the,
the animal sentiment,
uh,
then I think we do so at the,
at the cost of our intellectual enrichment.
Right?
Well,
and also there's the issue of,
um,
you know,
it is the individual versus the society thing,
right?
Uh,
where the individual does a create something that is basically hate Gaylene in
nature because we don't just pop things out of the air.
Uh,
the information that exists before that,
uh,
that is your thesis.
You add something new to it,
that's your,
uh,
antithesis.
You get something out of it.
That synthesis,
that synthesis is your creation.
Um,
should you benefit from it?
Sure.
Because you have done something that,
that,
that no one else has done before,
but you also didn't do it independent of the rest of the community in which you
live.
We do grant as they say,
uh,
an exclusive right to profit from it for a certain amount of time.
Um,
but what's really important about that is that is the individual that has the
right to profit from it,
uh,
and so on,
so forth.
So when you have,
and the great thing about individuals is that they die right in this particular
setup because eventually everything about,
uh,
what the individual does stops being of importance to that individual because
they're dead.
And then it becomes of the use to,
uh,
the society in general unless they previously,
licensed it or do whatever it else to,
to let it let it happen.
When you have a situation where,
for example,
um,
the individual dies,
and then their children and grandchildren and so on,
so forth,
then become rent seekers on that particular piece of property.
Um,
then to go back to the question of his wealth,
uh,
and moral,
then you start having the,
a real question of the morality of it relative to the benefit of the society in
general.
My personal feeling about stuff like this,
and I think it's maybe slightly different from yours,
is I'm a big fan of copyright for individuals being life plus 20 or 75 years,
whichever is longer in the case of the individual because the 20 then allows
the,
uh,
the person's,
spouse and family to get some limited benefit after that.
Um,
but after that it goes in,
it goes into the community.
Um,
because quite honestly,
my grandchildren should go either get their own jobs or walk away,
right?
Uh,
one of those,
one of those two things,
uh,
for corporations,
I think 75.
And the problem is,
is that you have folks like Disney as much as I,
you know,
I admire Disney in many other ways,
but the fact that every time scene,
but willy comes up to be about being put into public domain,
they somehow magically,
uh,
get to extend the life of,
although only one year to do it now because we're starting to,
we're coming up against the limits of the 20 year renewal in 1998.
So we're,
we're pretty close to it.
Don't worry,
we live in Trump's America.
I hear you.
Where we're a legislation passes with ease.
Um,
but uh,
so as far as,
and so as far as that goes,
I mean,
there is that thing that at a certain point,
um,
the individual ceases to exist.
The benefit to the individual crews from it,
um,
goes away and it has to go
back to the society because the society needs that had galean process to create
new and compelling stuff.
I want to suggest a gloss or a friendly amendment.
Please do,
which is that,
um,
in addition to this,
you need an expensive,
a safety valve for,
for a free expression.
Oh yeah.
That doesn't prevent the author from or that doesn't allow the author to enjoin
people from using their work to criticize their work.
Oh yeah.
And so,
you know,
I,
I think that we worry too much about things like open licenses and too little
about things like limitations to copyright,
like fair use.
Right.
Our Pollstar shouldn't be,
I can write the wind done gone,
which was a retelling of gone with the wind from the perspective of the enslaved
people.
If Margaret Mitchell tells me I can write right.
And therefore what we should do is kind of work on Margaret Mitchell's estate to
let two to get her to let us tell that story.
What we should be saying is Margaret Mitchell's the state and this is what the
Supreme Court affirmed.
Margaret Mitchell's estate doesn't get to decide,
right.
This is,
and so we don't have to,
and in that regard,
like the duration of copyright becomes a lot less important.
Right.
Cause one of the greatest problems with a copy of,
of copyright a term is that it is accompanied by a very narrow view of
limitations to copyright.
Right?
And so we not only have a very long lived thing but a very wide thing right now.
I accept this glass and endorse it and pull heartedly,
uh,
are we doing for time timewise?
But we've got time for mark via.
Okay.
So next question from someone who identifies as female or non binary please.
Yup.
Right here.
Yes.
Really curious how you came up with the ship name is Rick collapsing empire.
Great.
Thank you.
Um,
uh,
to have specific,
um,
it,
the,
it's a sort of sub Rosa,
not really a sub Rosa.
It's a kind of an explicit,
uh,
test,
you know,
testimonial to Enn banks,
right?
Whose culture series I absolutely love,
create,
you know,
creates the idea of a,
a huge,
um,
you know,
galaxy spanning civilization.
Now he writes with a sort of verve and complexity and,
uh,
that I don't,
um,
and in the sense of,
you know,
even just in the sentences,
I mean,
we all have complicated universes.
That's why you love us.
But,
uh,
but just the fact of his culture and the way that he's built that and there's
that,
there's so much there and even so much more implied.
Um,
I absolutely love.
and uh,
he and I were up for a locus of word together when I did red shirts and I
remember,
and he had just passed or was about to pass away.
And I remember explicitly saying to people,
I'm,
I'm absolutely happy that I've,
I'm a finalist for this award.
If you were planning to vote for me,
please vote for in banks.
Because not only was the hydrogen Sonata a wonderful book in and of itself,
but just as a,
you know,
a proxy for the entire series.
I was like,
this would be a great time in place to,
to honor him.
Um,
I won,
uh,
my wife gave my acceptance speech in which I dedicated it to him because again,
I just like,
I won,
but he should have,
um,
so this is,
this is his,
um,
and this is my way in,
in my creating this galaxy spanning a thing to acknowledge that Ian Banks is,
is a master of this particular form.
Um,
and so every time someone sees that and goes,
Huh,
it's like in banks,
it's almost like spinning the prayer wheel,
you know,
in my bookie in banks is remembered.
Uh,
and that actually makes me happy.
I sneak my favorite William Gibson line until you
get some light into about three quarters of my books,
which is don't let the little fuckers generation gap here.
Right,
right,
right.
And it's in like,
it appears in like half a dozen of them.
I want to ask about that because you know,
earth has a thousand years gone,
right.
The truth is lost to this civilization,
but they're all cool old tin Pan Alley songs.
Do you have a continuity in mind?
Does that kind of emerge?
Like,
why Tin Pan Alley I think.
I think,
I think it's just basically the classical music of its time.
Oh,
right,
right.
Um,
so they'll,
they'll pull it off.
And I think it's also,
there may be some sort of thing where you want to eat your ship names have to be
distinctive enough that they're not going to be a,
that they're not going to repeat repeat,
but at the same time have to be easy enough to remember that you can say them in
song lyrics.
Do a really good job of that.
I think there's that thing that,
uh,
for,
you know,
you shouldn't do this for passwords.
Uh,
but a long time ago people were like,
if you have a hard time remembering a thing,
just use,
uh,
initialisms yeah.
A line or a line of lyrics from a song or something like that.
You shouldn't do it because those,
once you actually see the pattern,
then it gives it all away.
And even a machine can figure that out.
But,
uh,
just the idea that you can remember a sequence of,
of,
uh,
words better than you might remember,
just a single word is kind of interesting too.
There's a thing called Zoo crows triangle,
which says that identifiers can be human readable,
unique or collision resist.
I forget what the third one is.
Do you remember,
remember what the third corner of is triangle was,
but,
but it is this problem,
right?
When you have independent people coming up with identifiers without being able
to talk to each other,
right?
Right.
That you have this really hard problem and you can use Hashes,
but like,
you know,
calling your spaceship,
the 80 character hash of something is a,
it's,
it,
it lacks,
it's not a kind of thing that people write songs about it and it's,
it really is the difference between,
you know,
uh,
having a personalized license plate and having a bin number.
Right,
right.
Uh,
okay,
one last question.
MMM.
You had your hand up first.
I'm sorry.
So John,
I was curious about,
um,
you mentioned in your book that society kind of has this infrastructure that
they take for granted.
And then there's also been kind of this loss of knowledge as to why he existing
principles by it kind of existed.
And you mentioned that someone people draw the conclusion that you're maybe
referring or it's an allegory about oil.
Um,
but I actually think of it as an allegory for another modern day infrastructure
that we're a little bit famous working with that people potentially take for
granted.
Um,
and I'm,
I'm curious,
especially with one of the groups that's currently tasked with protecting it,
I'm also recently publishing rules to kind of erode,
um,
key parts of why it exists and why it's important.
Um,
and,
and just this thought that every death is kind of its own destruction of a
library of Alexandria is,
you know,
you lose a family member.
Maybe I should have asked them something before they left or you know,
I lost a team member and now suddenly for code,
right?
Like I should have called this function,
holding a lock in.
Now I have a race condition kind of thing.
It's like this information,
it's,
it's not quite codified,
but it's important.
And because it wasn't distilled in because others were educated about it,
it's kind of lost in time.
Do either of you have thoughts on how we can better,
um,
kind of codified and educate others about these things?
Okay.
I,
you danced around what it was that you were actually trying to describe what I
thought crap first you were going towards Google books or something.
Uh,
but what is,
what is the,
for you,
what were you referring to explicitly as curious about net neutrality?
Neutrality.
Ah,
I'm going to let Corey talk first.
well look,
I mean the network neutrality question on its face should be really easy to
square up.
Like even if you don't want to,
even if you're,
you believe in markets,
uh,
as the solution to everything and you think regulation is a problem.
Phone companies don't exist without regulation,
right?
Like arguing about whether or not phone companies should or shouldn't be
regulated.
It's like arguing about whether or not,
um,
uh,
you know,
ice cream should be cold,
right?
Like if you,
you're the,
the like going Gault fiber network involves going to every basement in New York
and paying the clearing price of digging it up to put a piece of fiber in it
that is like a empty trillion dollars and you will never ever recoup it,
right?
So without some regulatory intervention that gives you these literally priceless
rights of way,
priceless because you would get this deadlock where when you got down to the
last two basements that control the,
the closing of the loop,
those people would just price it at the end,
like the entire expected return minus $1.
And so,
you know,
there's no viable way to build a telecomm without,
um,
without state intervention into property rights.
And so if you're going to take the king's shilling,
right,
if you're going to put your copper in our dirt that we clear the way for for
you,
then you have,
uh,
we have a,
you have an obligation to operate that copper in the public interest and you are
welcome to run your network any way you want.
If you're going to pay all the clearing costs associated with it,
but when you're going to use our large s right,
when you're going to take a giant subsidy,
that subsidy comes with a quid pro quo and that quid pro quo is,
you can give me the bits I asked for when I asked for them as quickly as you can
not,
you know,
like trading me to another prisoner for a pack of cigarettes,
right?
Going to one pro one,
one company or another and saying like,
how much will you pay me to,
to get your bits to Mr doctor o faster than you know,
uh,
the guys down the road.
Well,
and the fact that you have people who claim to be market supporters who are
unable to understand this is tells you that like the,
the thing gets menkens aphorism that it's impossible to get someone to
understand something when his paycheck depends on him not understanding it.
That,
that,
you know,
the arguments are so crummy for allowing network discrimination and Susan
Crawford had a great op ed about it today.
I think that we are almost at the point where maybe network neutrality will uh,
be very hard to take away because we are almost at the point where we have
pretty good networks for enough people that taking that away will cause them to
rise up because it's very hard to get people exercise to a bit of a thing
they've never had that we were telling them their future has been stolen from
them.
Right.
You know,
this is one of the problems with DRM is that we say like w there are all these
devices that should exist now but don't because it's against the law to break
DRM even for a legal purpose.
And so you stick a CD in your computer and it wakes up some software that came
for the manufacturer that says,
I see you're visiting us from the 20th century.
Would you like to move your music into the 21st and handily?
Puts it on your,
on your mobile device and lets you turn it into a ringtone alarm tone and
everything else.
Stick a DVD and it all it will do was what it could do in 1996 which is play it
right 20 years,
not one new feature added to DVD and um,
p people don't notice.
Right.
They don't even notice that there is nothing that happens when you do with a DVD
that when you put a DVD in,
apart from what it did 20 years ago,
but if they could do all the things with DVDs that they can do with cds and then
we told them they couldn't do it anymore,
there would be blood in the streets.
And what Obama was very canny about was creating an unsustainable healthcare
system that nevertheless insured 22 million uninsured people who were then when
that system ran up against the limits of the compromises he had to make with the
insurers to get it through would instead of saying,
all right then I guess we'll go back to the old bad ways would,
would then plump for single payer.
Yeah.
No,
I was wondering when we would get to health care on that because that is
cause by,
that is the one that they know
that really does bring a point to what he's saying there.
I mean the fact is is that if all of a sudden I have to pay an extra $20 for the
tier that allows me to get Netflix,
right,
which I already get for free minus the Netflix subscription costs or the tier
that,
that it basically goes into the cable model,
um,
then people are going,
yeah,
people are going to freak out about it because they,
they already have it.
That's there already ground level expectation and it's the,
the,
once you give people something and you'd give it sufficient time to take root as
that is the expectation,
that is always going to be a part of that expectation.
And you do have any,
and you do have basically what are I would say,
uh,
Randy and acolytes going,
well,
no,
we should actually do it this particular way and,
and pair away everything that doesn't allow you to or that,
that,
uh,
has anything to do with the government doing anything other than shooting people
and saying,
oh no,
this is more efficient.
And of course we can trust other people to do that.
Um,
and it,
it just doesn't work.
I mean,
implicit in a lot of the philosophies that lead to something like breaking net
neutrality or taking away the,
uh,
health care that other people have is the assumption that,
um,
the only things that exist are you and the ground no more than six feet under
you.
Right?
And so that everything else will just sort of take care of itself.
And of course it doesn't.
And that's,
uh,
that's the aspect I think of both of our books.
Everything is interconnected.
Everything works together or it doesn't.
But there's always going to be,
uh,
factors that you have to deal with.
Uh,
I obviously,
and I think this is a noncontroversial statement,
think that trying to reverse the net neutrality is purely a stupid,
uh,
it doesn't benefit anyone but a certain number of small people,
again,
up at the top.
Um,
it,
uh,
is going to present real issues for,
the vast majority of people at the bottom,
uh,
and the potential for the Internet,
and the potential for these networks,
uh,
which is to,
um,
ha who have the potential to raise up and then flatten out.
Uh,
things like access,
things like education,
things like,
uh,
communication,
goes away simply for the benefit of three or four or five companies and the
attendance,
CEO's and executive class with those shareholders.
You know,
and,
and bluntly,
and I'm sorry that I'm going to use a bad word here on the Google streaming
thing.
Fuck that.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm not here for the top 10.
I'm speaking as someone who is in the 1% myself.
I'm not here for,
for those people.
I want the benefit of this for everyone because I also have come down from the
very bottom of our,
you know,
US society and I know how crappy and how awful it is and how trivial it is to
improve the lives of people,
uh,
at the bottom through things like access to computers,
to things like networks,
to things like education.
Um,
and so every time,
uh,
you know,
you have an administration like this administration,
uh,
which is just full scale and you know,
let's,
let's sprint as fast as we possibly can towards oligarchy cause to the rest of
you.
Um,
then yeah,
I,
you get my back up.
Um,
so,
uh,
the current head of the FCC can,
go dunk his head in the toilet and flush several times.
As far as I'm concerned,
we need net neutrality.
Yeah,
exactly.
Let's hear it again for John and Corey.
That was awesome.
Okay.